Omar claims that the translations were
slanted by
propagandists yeah I've seen I've seen
rep that I'm always worried about that
when I'm seeing stuff on Twitter like
going viral and they're like and it's
got you know don't retweet them yeah
yeah because you don't know you just
don't know and now with deep fakes dude
yeah when when someone's talking into a
mic and you can't really see their mouth
and this is all you you know people
you're watching the camera and I you
could you could AI deep fake anything MH
mhm I show I showed Tim the video of Joe
Biden in front of a green screen with
the boom mic going through his hand and
anything's fake remember that the that
was that was a weird video anything
anything is fake anything you guys
remember that one where Joe Biden walks
up to the the Press core whatever and he
and he leans forward and then all a
sudden one of the mics is like in front
of his or no it's like under his hand
yeah it kind of looks like it goes right
through his hand it's just very strange
I as if he was in front of a green
screen I think he is in front of a green
screen a l but he does film on a Sound
Stage semi do that but there were other
angles of this yeah that looked normal
there were there were but I think he's
there a clone sometimes a deep fake or
AI